and finally new rule no matter which
side wins on tuesday let's skip the
civil war
and go right to reconciliation
34 of the voters think there will be
another civil war in the next five years
and i'd like to remind them of one thing
america is a family and the definition
of family
is people who hate each other without
resorting to violence
we have to see each other not as mortal
enemies but rather merely as roommates
from hell
if we want to simply exist
we're going to have to find a way to
work together
like the rolling stones a lot like the
rolling stones because we also need a
comeback tour to pay the bills
so let's not have a civil war with the
trumpers we're no good at war
and they're no good at being civil
like them or not they're not going
anywhere neither side is
the only people who ever threaten to
leave the country are rich celebrities
and none of them ever do
people keep sending me these maps
showing how red states and blue states
should just go our separate ways
we'll get new york they'll get texas
shut the [ __ ] up
take it from someone who has traveled
this country my whole life there are no
red states or blue states they're all
like mitch mcconnell's hand
some shade of purple
we can't have a second civil war because
the two
sides aren't neatly separated anymore
you see
the mason dixon line of today would cut
through states
cities streets even bedrooms
we're amongst each other now all swirled
together and marbled in
there are 3.8 million hillary voters in
texas and 4.5 million
trump voters in california we can't go
to war
my dry cleaner is behind enemy lines
i don't want to fight the battle of
trader joe's
we have got to figure out ways to start
working with each other again and the
way we've always done that in the past
is with a
grand bargain mr president you must know
this
you're the big deal maker and i know you
watch the show every week by accident
by accident
you're like the guy in the emergency
room who darn the luck keeps getting a
zucchini stuck up his head
i don't know how it happened again
but here's a grand bargain that could
work for everybody
if liberals lose we won't loot foot
locker
and if you lose you don't loot the
treasury
that's that's how we get america back
with a grand bargain
on looting because i'll admit our side
has lately
been having a little trouble saying
looting is bad
like axios cheerily reported that
looting can have positive effects
because it generates cash for the
looters yes stealing usually does
there's even a book called in defense of
looting the author says
looting provides people with an
imaginative sense of freedom and
pleasure
so does masturbating in a zoom meeting
but we don't recommend it
have we lost our minds stealing bad
no looting them all and also no gucci
loafered republican looters ransacking
the government
because i know what
i know what you're thinking don
you lose the election and everything
must go lost our lease going out of
business
oh yes you'll be selling pardons on
craigslist
jared will turn the smithsonian into
condos
you're going to try to strip this
government like it's an abandoned range
rover in a bad neighborhood
as we speak they are trying to pull off
one final
giant swampy scam with the new 5g
a deal one official said is perhaps the
biggest handoff of economic power to a
single entity in history
after the jeff bezos divorce of course
yeah 5g trump's cronies are cutting
themselves in
this is looting on a much grander scale
than boosting the window display at
lululemon
and they're doing it with the pandemic
as well in september
the stock price of kodak surged
because they were given a huge contract
to make pandemic drugs
with one small problem kodak doesn't
make drugs
they make cameras in 1985.
kodak who was the second highest bidder
for this the gap
stop stealing is this really such a hard
thing for americans to agree on
can we agree on something anything
because it's getting a little chippy out
there so please
whatever happens tuesday let's find a
way to live together
we have to because no other country will
take us
you